es el momento de hablar de economía con
danielle hablando de daniela buenas
noches para usted hola buenas noches
angela vamos a empezar daniela
conversando de este profundo cambio de
postura que hubo en la reserva federal
de eeuu para enfrentar la crisis
angela primero hay que explicar que la
misión de todo banco central es
básicamente definir las tasas de interés
que rigen en un país pero esta misión se
vuelve más difícil cuando esta tarea
implica además mantener el equilibrio
entre un buen crecimiento económico y la
inflación controlada lo que pasó hoy en
medio de esa crisis es que la reserva
federal ahora busca dejar las tasas
bajas en el mediano plazo para priorizar
el empleo y sacrificando un poco los
precios de la canasta básica es decir la
inflación y es que la última semana las
peticiones de subsidios siguieron por
encima del millón sus efectos sobre el
bolsillo los explica un experto
en el entorno actual todos estamos
viendo tasas de interés históricamente
bajas y los beneficiarios de esos son
aquellos que tienen inversiones en el
mercado de valores aquellos que buscan
comprar una casa obtener una hipoteca o
refinanciar una hipoteca aquellos que
son efectivamente penalizados por el
entorno actual de tasas de interés bajas
son los ahorradores porque se trata de
personas que generalmente tienen
ingresos fijos y están viendo una tasa
de rendimiento muy baja de sus ahorros
bueno vamos a cambiar de tema hay más
interesados en comprar tick tock
cuéntenos si aunque muchos de ellos son
apenas rumores lo que sí se sabe es que
si las operaciones de la empresa de
china en eeuu salen a la venta pues va a
tener un buen ramillete de pretendientes
a mike el susto que es el que suena con
más fuerza se unió hoy el gigante wal
mart que de paso se anotó casi un 5% de
ganancia en wall street con el solo
anuncio pero también hay otros posibles
candidatos como ahora que lo twitter
todas ellas estadounidenses la casa
blanca busca que esta transacción se
complete antes del 15 de septiembre y en
medio de las negociaciones justamente
hoy
ex disney que billmeyer renunció como
presidente de la compañía y apenas
llevaba tres meses en el cargo de la muy
lamentable y brasil e busca eliminar
temporalmente los aranceles a ciertos
productos agrícolas estamos hablando de
productos como soja arroz y maíz y el
objetivo de la medida es hacerle frente
al aumento de precios de estos alimentos
en el mercado interno esta situación se
debe a que brasil ha venido exportando
todo lo que tiene en soja recordemos que
es uno de los mayores exportadores y
aunque el gobierno dice que no hay
escasez si reconoce que las
importaciones están subiendo a causa de
la pandemia si miramos los ganadores y
perdedores de esta medida que todavía
está en discusión pues argentina y
paraguay le pueden vender más soja y
uruguay más arroz pero si brasil les
quita los aranceles a todo el resto del
mundo eeuu se los llevaría por delante a
esos tres países
daniela los camioneros en chile
iniciaron una huelga nacional cuéntenos
de qué se trata
bueno esta es una manera de protestar
por la violencia que los tiene azotados
en la región de araucanía así como el
lento avance en el congreso de una serie
de proyectos de ley sobre la operación
de los camiones el paro inició con el
bloqueo de una vía que de santiago hacia
la ciudad portuaria de valparaíso se
dirige por eso uno de los temores tiene
que ver con una posible interrupción de
la cadena de suministro de alimentos y
medicinas pues este país depende del
transporte por carretera todo estalló
después de que una niña de nueve años
fuera fue herida de bala por tratar de
robar a su papá quien conducía un camión
o con cemento en esta región apenas uno
de muchos ataques que se vienen
presentando últimamente en la zona
daniela los indicadores de la jornada el
anuncio de la fed movió a casi todos los
mercados bursátiles del mundo comenzando
por wall street cuyo índice standard and
poor's 500 marcó su tercer día
consecutivo de récord histórico en
europa también estuvieron motivados por
la fed pero el resultado fue negativo en
casi todas sus principales plazas
bursátiles ahora nos vamos a américa
latina donde se notó un fuerte descenso
por cuarto día consecutivo en la bolsa
de comercio de buenos aires también
brasil cerró idéntica a la jornada del
miércoles bueno llega mi momento
preferido de este reportaje sobre
economía para cuál es la cifra de la
jornada mire son los 200 mil millones de
dólares que la revista forbes calcula
que tiene la fortuna de jeff bezos quien
es el dueño de amazon con esto se
convierte en la primera persona en el
mundo en lograr semejante patrimonio
angela supera al fundador de microsoft
bill gates quien en 1999 llegó a una
cifra que a precios equivalentes de hoy
sería de unos 158 mil
esto sería mucho más alto si no se
hubiera separado de su esposa porque
recordemos que le dio unas acciones de a
más
dios santo muchas gracias daniel a
ustedes sigan con nosotros esto es unas
[Música]